the global financial crisis that we
experience in requires that political
leaders and business leaders get
together and work out solutions global
with our solutions that will bring a
more sustainable the solutions to the
crisis and this framework is not enough
this framework is not sufficient
citizens ordinary citizens must do a lot
in fact we say go back to Kennedy and
paraphrase Kennedy ask not what leaders
can do to bring about an end to the
global economic crisis but rather what
you can do as a citizen to bring about
change to bring about solutions to the
crisis we're facing as a globe what does
this require it requires us to revisit
our values it requires us to say what am
i doing in my business that will
contribute to the solution of the crisis
as opposed to increase and enhance the
crisis in particular we must redefine
what success means what is success for a
company what is successful community for
a family let us move away from a profit
driven strategy but go through a triple
bottom line approach that says the
impact on society is important the
impact on the environment is important
as an individual consumer what is the
impact I'm having on society as an
individual citizen what is in fact I'm
having on the environment in other words
it has charged espada let's judge
ourselves using a framework a value
system that says society environment and
profits this can be done at a personal
level this can be done by individuals
individuals must reduce their levels of
consumption
what is your carbon consumption as an
individual what kind of car are you
driving in terms of consumption or fuel
in terms of pollution
how energy-efficient is your system that
you use it in the house what kind of
lighting system are you employing what
kind of batteries are you using are you
recycling as an individual what have you
done in the community to make a
difference as a person as an individual
what are you doing in the school system
to promote education in other words we
are encouraging the individual to become
a change agent when correcting the
individual to understand the nature of
the global financial crisis and then
encouraging them to respond at a
personal level and offer solutions and
as we do this we don't want the African
citizen to be second-class citizen we
want the African citizen when the
citizen from the poor countries to do
the same by also becoming part of these
solutions to the issues around the
global financial crisis in particular we
want to drive entrepreneurship we want
to move away from even being a worker in
other words as individuals ask ourselves
how many jobs have I created as an
individual how many companies have I
created so we are say it is incumbent
upon every citizen to become a player in
terms of driving the economy in terms of
growing the economy and the growth of
the economy itself is not enough it was
be a shared economic growth strategy and
this is what is required of the
individual this is what is required of
the citizen in every country and also in
doing this we must encourage more people
to take positions in public leadership
to check positions in political
leadership most of our best minds are in
the private sector most of our best
minds are in academia most of our best
minds are in journalism most of our best
minds are in the NGO communities and
mediocrity dominates politics if we do
this we are ruining the future of our
glogg we must find a way to
encourage our superstars are high
performers to move into the public
sector we must encourage more young
global leaders more people come to
divorce to get into the public sector
and become political leaders this is a
calling that must be understood at a
personal level in addition to this
individuals citizens must move away from
the Maslow hierarchy of needs is defined
by Maslow Maslow's hierarchy of needs
start with shelter food and ends up with
self-actualization as the highest stage
we are saying that is a moribund model
we need to modify it and say how can I
go beyond self how can I sell transcend
and leave a legacy make a difference in
the lives of the people around me this
is the challenge to the citizen this is
the challenge to the individual to be
able to say I have some transcended and
gone beyond self I've left a legacy in
my community I have left a legacy in the
world I've made a dent to the universe
this can be done we shall overcome if as
individuals who step up to the plate and
be counted